oh my god Katie Price's quitting YouTube
have you heard about it from news media
[Music]
good evening I'm puppy's Moria PD pi has
quit YouTube the story is everywhere
YouTube megastar pretty Pike waits PD pi
reveals real reason he has quit YouTube
yes quit everyone did you know did you
know pretty pious quit breaking
pewdiepie quakes YouTube it this is so
sad no more PewDiePie guess it's just
gonna be me now
Papa's Moria pew die by world's biggest
YouTube star PewDiePie quoits saying
he's feeling very tired boo-hoo-hoo I
especially like this CNN one because
it's basically PewDiePie who became one
of YouTube's biggest stars before we're
seeing his career dogged by allegations
of racism and anti-semitism we'll be
away for a little while Philip is taking
a break because the racism man I can't
believe this God blown up I am blown
away that it got blown up you know this
is posted not just in you if you're from
I don't know anywhere in Europe or
whatever the this your local news might
have reported on this as well cuz it's
just one of those stories that caught
fire for whatever reason I think first
of all we should look at what I said
because I think the contrast is so funny
it was at the end of my last few news
Pappas Moria I reported on it taking
break from YouTube next year I wanted to
say it in advance because I made up my
mind I'm tired I'm tired I'm feeling
very tired I don't know if you can tell
just so you know early next year I'll be
away for a little while I'll explain
that later but I wanted to give head
that's it that's all I said
early next year I'll be away for a
little while I never said I'm quitting I
said I'm taking a break
I find it so funny because the reason
why I announced it at the end of a video
and I hate the announcement of the
announcement it's so annoying right the
reason why I did it because I didn't
want to uh play it I just wanted it to
be I didn't want to make a surprise for
my audience as well and being like all
right some quick thing cuz that's what
youtubers would do if they go on a break
they would go like I'm quitting PT Pike
Waits
you know it's done before I get it but I
didn't want to do that I didn't want to
make a big deal out of it and then out
of all people news media blows it up why
do I have more integrity than 50 news
media this makes no sense
this is all wrong this is all backwards
I think this is a common practice in
media where well one person got it wrong
so we can all just get it wrong right
it's so dumb well there's all these
other news stories that reported the
wrong news so we can all report I don't
want to be all fake news but it is faith
that it is I don't know what to tell you
yeah I don't understand why no one reads
this stuff cuz it's so oh here we go
Disney oh N word Christchurch ad oh
there we go
we hit them all you just gotta get them
all out there in 20 years from now I
quit YouTube and do you think people
will post like 20 years ago we
remembered he said the N word you guys
remember that now I will not give my oh
my god this is so obnoxious
somebody pop-ups if I release this game
for making food thank you for posting
night it's taking a break from the
platform that launched what did they
change it the vlogger that's right yeah
I don't know why they referred to it as
a vlog sorry it had this low quality
version of this because they changed the
title he doesn't want to think about
vlogging anymore when did I say that
they put it in quote right what is that
the use those APIs strove to be like oh
no it's not an actual quote it's just we
just make it look like it's a quote
like what is that look if you look
closely we're not actually quoting him
we're just putting a straw
it's your stinky fault I'm not a blogger
I'm not even a vlogger how do you get it
so wrong to be Fred they did change it
because I deactivated my Twitter so that
now they can put quite straighter
because of this I got a lot of boomers
who don't know who I am
and they just read that I made 25
million and they're like my job is so
hard I don't make 25 million how dare
you take our break how could you take a
break my job harder
and I make less money I feel like I have
to explain why I'm taking a break now
just because this is just gonna become
weirder oh wait there was another
sentiment I read that was really funny
oh here we go here broke the news to
heartbroken fans in the latest peer news
video no one on my fans were heartbroken
they knew that I was going to take a
break anyway and that's why I wanted to
make clear that I'm I decided that I'm
gonna do it and the reason why no one of
my fans are heartbroken is because they
understand that is normal to just take a
break I didn't see anyone say oh my god
so sad they already knew about it it's
so like why are you making that up
alright this is addressed to all the
boomers I've been uploading YouTube
videos every single day for 10 years
YouTube is the kind of job that isn't
very stable they're always changing
legislation and rules and policies and
blah blah blah and it's such a new thing
that any day it could be over for anyone
and and that has been the process for a
lot of youtubers in the past so since
I'm keeping this opportunity to be a
youtuber I've decided I'm gonna make the
most out of it no matter what and I've
done that and as I think a lot of my
success comes from the fact that I am so
consistent with on this platform
I don't pre record videos because I
think that loses its touch and a lot of
things like that god damn this sounds so
preachy it's the point is I thought
YouTube would be over by now for me I
thought I would be last like two years
or something like that but here I am I
don't want to look at myself another ten
years in the future and I've done the
exact same thing as I've done now even
though I really enjoy and love what I do
I don't want to look back on my life 20
years later more like oh cool so I just
did YouTube
and I never ever did anything else it
just seems kind of sad to me another
reason I think it's important for anyone
to take a break no matter what job you
have it I think that's important and
that so much has happened there's here
that I just been building up and up and
up and up and I never had never taken a
break before I don't know what it feels
like to not worry about uploading a
video even when I am away on on certain
things I'm still uploading during that
time so I'm just still monitoring the
video I'm still making sure everything
is good and micromanaging and I've never
just had a full stop so I just want to
know what that feels like that's it I
didn't want to make a big deal out of it
but now I felt like I was forced to
explain it plus it will be so good
sometime early next year we even kept
the honeymoon five days like even things
like that as a minimum and that's just
kind of sad and I think it's gotten
their point where okay it's cool I love
you too but if I want to keep it going
I kind of want to change a couple things
and be able to not be so strict with it
it's like if you're an entrepreneur you
put your heart and soul and and you work
your ass off to make this project work
that you have right but then once you
made it you kind of simmer down and you
let it let other people take in control
or you might sell the company or
whatever you do but for me the project
it's myself I'm there still I can't sell
myself I can let someone else step in so
it's it's so I'm 100 solely dependable
if how this channel is doing so it's
hard to just slack off do you understand
does that make sense
cool I don't I didn't make the whole
thing to be boohoo me oh it's so hard I
want a break that's not it at all just
want to be clear on that
I understand there's jobs that are way
tougher than mine I'm very happy to be
in the situation I'm not trying to I
don't want people sympathy I never asked
for it next news another story that
interested me was the fact that Tana
[ __ ]
yes YouTube Streamy Awards you to put
their actual actual logo on this really
okay here are the nominees for creator
of the year creator of the year why does
their overlay look like the h3h3 podcast
[Music]
and lets you easily see who left the
platform she's nominated for creator of
the year though she doesn't leave the
platform for traditional media's oh
that's hilarious there's such a gap now
on YouTube between creators and the ones
that are so desperate to be validated by
by mainstream media more in gray I don't
even open that inner beast mr. banks
ninja ninja okay Sophia Nygaard I don't
know myself
EPIK a kids channel Tana mojo Dada [ __ ]
well obviously mr. beech is gonna win it
I mean he had such an amazing impact
this year his growth has been insane
he's like the one channel that doesn't
have any big controversy he's done good
on this on the platform what he's done
so many other youtubers try and
replicate it's obvious some of the other
new animations did they're good okay but
as obvious mr. Bies is gonna win it
wait did you see the name or that's who
you think it is it is not david dobrik
I'm sorry David but you've won like
every award tonight it's only fair Tana
[Applause]
had to come out it in her pajama still
made it to the show it's so cringe to
rip on Tana like yeah she's insufferable
I don't want to make a whole deal out of
it
and I stood right here a year ago and I
literally held Shane Dawson's award and
the first thing I said to all of you
people was like I will never be creators
be here I'm so glad they filmed Gus
Johnson's reaction yeah guys when Tanner
said I don't deserve this we all felt
that
[Applause]
she's so humble she doesn't feel like
creator of the air she's so
down-to-earth she's just like us no you
literally don't deserve it that's why
you feel like tanks I'm not actually mad
about this because everyone knows award
shows are just fake anyway it's all
politics it's all based on who is there
they want to be show that they're giving
away awards to people instead of just
having people show up in videos or not
accepting the award at all so the people
that playing to the whole award show
thing are the people that get the award
I've literally gotten award shows
writing to me saying hey we want to give
you this award but you have to come
there to get it and it's like no I don't
want it thing it doesn't mean anything I
literally don't even keep my awards that
I have actually gone because I don't
feel proud of them
I think it's it doesn't mean anything
but I think the main reason you know
it's fine that it is that way but it is
also kind of sad because I think it
could be cool to actually have it as a
way to actually celebrate the people
that did something amazing this year
just like rewind could be something like
that right a celebration of what people
accomplished or made a mark or made an
impact I think that's what it that's
literally it it doesn't have to be more
than that oh yeah and this was fan voted
as well so it's it's not about who made
the most impact it's who can get the
their audience to vote the most amount
of times right who can get their
audience to give you this award
basically and if that was genuine as
well like if no one if the if it was
just a poll and no one's told anyone to
go there specifically but if you tell
your audience over and over to go and
vote for you then
yeah it doesn't that kind of feed the
purpose I'm sure if mr. Bies campaigned
to win he would win but what kind of
award is that to accept and it's so
funny to me how he makes the whole thing
[Music]
as if the award was actually chosen to
her I hate Tana mainly because she
promotes drugs to her 14 year old
audience I don't know how they are but
like weeds legal they're okay
I'm so high right now and I'm not even
on adderall that was so like I'll take
the go forth of a 20 milligram felt like
five milligrams of adderall the blood I
wasn't gonna smoke weed today in those
days like this I really loved my life
[Music]
and I was like yeah those are a lot of
you guys for some reason I've been
bringing me marijuana that's creator of
the year
I don't mean to bring up a bunch of old
stuff I don't want to do the whole media
meme but I generally haven't followed
what she's doing I know she had that MTV
show did I get canceled Jake Paul
antennas MTV show was cancelled after
announcement three days ago all right
that's all the news for this pier news
hope you guys enjoyed smash like
subscribe and also guys I have an
announcement next year I'm taking a
break from snapchat I know and my
LinkedIn profile I'm thinking about
taking a break from that as well
hopefully noose me there will not get
the story right this time but I think
I'm very tired
and I think it's time for me to take a
break bye bye bye bye
[Music]
you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the own poop
[Music]
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne routine is the game to play I'm
not supposed to have my opinion about
that but the prizes
you